Three reasons why we should continue
using nuclear energy.
One: nuclear energy saves lives.
In 2013, a study conducted by NASA found
that nuclear energy has prevented
around 1.8 million deaths.
Even if you include the death tolls from
Chernobyl and Fukushima,
nuclear energy ranks last in death per
energy unit produced.
While nuclear waste is really toxic,
it’s usually stored somewhere,
while the toxic byproducts of fossil fuels
are pumped into the air
we breathe every day.
So, just by reducing the amount of fossil
fuels burned, countless cases of cancer
or lung disease and accidents in
coal mines have been avoided.
If we can choose between lots of dangerous
stuff being put into a deep hole and
lots and lots and lots of dangerous stuff
being pumped into the atmosphere,
the former seems more logical.
Nuclear energy feels way
more dangerous, though.
Single catastrophic events burn into our
memory, while coal and oil kill silently.
It’s like the death rate of
flying versus driving.
Even in the best-case scenario, it would
take at least forty years to switch
to 100%-renewable energy.
So, for as long as we continue using
fossil fuels, nuclear energy will save
way more lives than it destroys.
Two: nuclear energy reduces CO₂ emissions.
Nuclear energy is arguably way less
harmful to the environment
in terms of climate change than fossil
fuels, our main source of energy.
Since 1976, about 64 gigatons of
greenhouse gas emissions
have not been pumped out thanks
to nuclear energy.
And by the mid-21st century, that could
amount to an additional 80–240 gigatons.
Humanity’s energy consumption is
rising steadily.
According to US government projections,
China alone will add the equivalent of
a new 600-MW coal plant every 10 days
for the next 10 years.
China already burns 4 billion tons of
coal each year.
Coal is cheap, relatively abundant, and
easy to get to.
So it’s not likely that humanity will stop
using it soon.
Nuclear energy might be the only way of
dampening the effects of climate change
and preventing a catastrophic man-made
global warming.
Compared to the other things we do,
nuclear energy is relatively clean.
So, even if it is a good idea to quit
nuclear energy long-term,
it might be a good solution for
the next hundred years or so,
compared to the alternatives.
Three: new technologies.
Maybe technology will solve the problem of
nuclear waste and dangerous power plants.
The nuclear reactors we’ve used so far are
mostly outdated technology,
because nuclear innovation
stopped in the 1970s.
There are models, like the
thorium reactor,
that could solve the problem altogether.
Thorium is abundant, really hard to turn
into nuclear weapons,
and up to two orders of magnitude less
wasteful than current nuclear reactors.
The waste material might also be only
dangerous for a few hundred years,
in contrast to a couple of thousand years.
1 ton of thorium is estimated to provide
the same amount of energy
as 200 tons of uranium or
3.5 million tons of coal.
So while we cannot know for sure if
alternative nuclear technology
will keep its promises, shouldn’t we at
least do more research
before we forego an opportunity to solve
lots of humanity’s current problems?
It may not be an easy challenge,
but that hasn’t stopped us before.
So, should we use nuclear energy?
There are risks involved in any great
human endeavor,
and we have to make an informed decision,
rather than rely on gut feeling.
If you want to hear the other
side of the argument, or
a short introduction to
nuclear energy, click here.